sto morendo per tutti ragazzi e
benvenuto questo video sono fa vj oggi
sto morendo ritor no scherzavo ragazzi
siamo su angry taurus home che sarebbe
un gioco bello dove c'è un nuovo con dei
baffi perché dio mi stavo scherzando non
solo anche la bellezza di quest'uomo che
minimi mi fa morire ma c'era una volta
perfetto a c'è un nuovo c'è un nuovo che
tenta di aggiustare un tostapane ecco è
così che si teneva chiave inglese bravo
zio e non ce la fa quindi è uscito è
finita com ragazzi best cinematica è un
2015 non c'è un cazzo di dubbio come si
fa sta roba da saltare quelli di in
preveniente devo saltare la no porca
[ __ ]
devo saltare da una parte che bello
bravo e non so perché ma così baffi mi
sa di toni quest'uovo lo chiamerò tony
scott a toni anti premi f per saltare
più in alto ok
sì ma devo incrocia le dita un
mongoloide ravetto anni non importa se
dobbiamo incrociare come mongola basta
che ce la fai
no toni no toni toni di merda bravo toni
sto andando in c o vinto questo è il
gioco della vita
io ero spies stai attento alle pale
punte infatti ci sono andato sopra port
che porta a [ __ ] ti è un posto tipo
porta venezia c'è anche porta puttan
chiuso fatto come lo hai saltato toni
non ho capito anch'io ma va bene ok no
no no cazzo sei schumacher è una roba
indecente ma va bene allora devo capire
ancora lontana la vacca [ __ ] capire la
gallina coi baffi che età cagato voglio
conoscerla fam lago non esce ti prego
cioè il gioco più difficile che abbia
mai provato nella mia vita
ok no ma [ __ ] quando finisce il
tutorial dovrebbe iniziare il gioco vero
io già non riesco a far questo figure
non ciclo dopo che ha fatta mio zio toni
quanto sei impedito cioè veramente
assurdo staccano dai ti supplico ciechi
atleta incredibile bravo toni
incredibili ciao ragazzi da adesso in
avanti no no perché sei brutto bravo
mezz'ora pasta cagata bravissimo no no
non so se avevo battuto per sicurezza
hanno dato un'altra botta c'è un buco
solo come che sei esperto perché c'era
la domanda che può agire perfetto bravo
toni c'è la roba oggi oggi oggi siamo in
vena di salti bravissimo complimenti
bravo bravo e mio ragazzo bravo il mio
ragazzo
ma allora c'è una punta sola perché devi
andare su quella ma cazzo
niente dice la mamma [ __ ] ci sto
credendo lega dai ma neanche che mario
mi fa incazzare così sentite ma è bravo
ok ok bra ho fatto cose che non rifarò
mai più nella vita sentite ragazza
diventando l'atroce no kat
io non mangerò più nulla a base di uova
parte il fatto che coi baffi in inquieta
quindi ok è la seconda che la nutella
non è a base di water novero perché se
non potrei morire
egli morì più tanto muoio uguale voglio
un personal trainer di nome toni in
palestra per tonificare e a casa per
ficcare tonificare e tonificare e un
gioco con un nuovo e dei baffi ok ci
posso fare mio dio di quello modo c'è
verso mai non c'è verso mai
oh oh madonna che stavo cadendo potuti
ragioni torno il mondo la madonna tutti
è una cosa tip cos'è questo è semplice
questo è questa questo non è semplice
vedete che riesco a morire anche dai
bravo zio bravo ce la possiamo questo
non era tanto difficile grazie a dio
abbiamo finito il tutorial credo di sì
ragazzi quindi adesso inizia la parte
difficile quello di prima non era
difficile non credete se fate i conti
col errani forte forte tutti io ce la
faccio li voglio vedere fare così tante
facce non mi sto sentendo lega forza che
pigrizia dai cazzo è che muoio se no
ragazzi mi volete veder morire mi volete
veder morire così dio mio
bravi dai forza tutti bra avete iniziato
non avete iniziato
battete per toni che non c'ha le braccia
ok ok bravo toni bravissimo ok perché ce
l'abbiamo fatta dopo anni di tentativi
perché si sta rompendo ragazzi si sta
rompendo toni no no no no no sì bravo
bravo una se.ga mi chiami sono salvato
di brutto
ho detto di nuovo di como dine woodcuts
che tese angola chiarimenti un nervoso
che non avete idea no toni noto a noi in
spite punte che annoiano ma veramente
guarda mi sto divertendo in realtà non
trovo di piano allora adesso prendi da
cazzo di bravo un altro ma no come un
altro noti per no no no non lo accetto
non lo accetto cazzo no [ __ ]
[ __ ] via f
un culo allora allora allora allora ok
no che sto alto fatto no no anche rima
che casa in difficoltà già sto gioco
rega ma è assurdo ma perché l'hanno
fatto incazzare me l'hanno fatto tonico
io non ho fatto per incastonare ok ok no
perché c'è il buco c'è il buco bravo
bravo sì
[Musica]
se fottutamente si cazzo due ore this is
my land che doubt lo ha sentito tp a
calci in faccia ad una vita di che cazzo
al passato io ti ammazzo la famiglia e
in culo sopita riuscito ascolta zio io
c'ho un paio di baffi tu non hai manco
la faccia che cazzo è questa la mia land
mag e che è che come ti permetti
no guardi arrivato alla fine toni versus
lander man dovrebbe essere la merda
perché non ha la faccia questa musica e
mi fa troppo ridere
ok arrivo puoi pup armeno tutto questo
lo infilo nel culo cielo fatte ragazzi
ho finito il primo lì il primo e cos'era
st stage estensi adesso crollano pure le
cose come se non basta rubio nera era
talmente facile che almeno adesso
aggiungono difficoltà grazie e
complimenti anche le spine che cos'è che
roba di merda andava bene come la prima
c'è non c'è bisogno di far bravo toni
bravissimo un salto della madonna
complimenti ma oscar diamogli un os che
abbiamo gliene 2003
diamogli nei quattro cinque schiaffi in
faccia porca put ma ho capi allora io
devo saltare quando ruota in realtà
perché da più spinta il problema è che
essendo un nuovo è una merda né ruotare
quindi non riesco a saltare questa è la
decisione no indietro che cazzo va
indietro che nasconde davanti vado
indietro allora cosa c'è di diverso sto
cazzo di scalino di spettacolo di prima
niente o si va indietro ti ammazzo la
famiglia te lo dico ti faccio crescere i
baffi anche a tuo figlio
madonna perché si sta rompendo che prima
non era così
ok mi sono rotto il cazzo altro che uovo
dai sì che goduria madonna madonna tutto
lui tutto a lui allora se non riesco a
saltare questo coso mi incazzo e me ne
vado giuro
no
li mortacci della sua famiglia sente
quando si cela frase che ne so
nel mondo ci sono sette miliardi di
persone non può rovinarti la giornata
una persona a me me l'ha rovinato un
cazzo di uovo coi baffi di merda no no
che cade che cade come tua madre che
cade dall'autostrada ieri è caduta ma il
bello ragazzi che c'è una musichetta del
cazzo sotto di sottofondo che non ti fa
godere appieno l'incazzatura e sono
pronto sulla punta lo sapevo io ma la
dai a a
ho fatto uno screenshot
papà ma vieni su ca mezz'ora vera che il
tuo cielo scritto sul canta non lo so
non ho idea di come abbia non me lo
chiedono anche guarda lascia perdere
stato due ore sullo stesso livello una
cosa indecente mi faceva nel cervello
che ci pensa questo caso tra secondi
livello quello fino a 12 anni
dio mio come bilanciano di merda i
livelli non sanno fare i giochi stata
casa ascolta toni senti facciamo questo
patto tumi finisci livelli ti giuro che
non comprano più nuovo non mangiano più
roba di uova cose con le uova
basta che non mi caghi bene bene se
verso dai sì o no
o ce l'abbiamo fatta grazie a definisco
stage di livelli e basta me ne vado
perché cazzo non si può fare una roba
veramente pessima c'è cazzo è strano
perché non capisci mai da che cosa devi
cliccare il mio dio va beh ma
qualcos'altro non so mettete anche majin
bu che minimi picchia avete voglia e non
so adesso tranquillo proprio tranquillo
tranquillissimo no ho detto tranquillo
oh oh oh dio mio santo bene dedaj allora
ascoltami toni ti prego ti regalo dei
baffi nuovi regalo anche dei capelli non
so una barbetta il pizzetto andresti
bene per pizza del terzito licu bravo
non te lo dò il pizzetto però se fai
così piano adesso ho motivo obiettivo
non mio dio mi sto sentendo male mi sto
sentendo il boss è quello grigio come si
chiama non so come ti chiami sei brutto
sul più bello ascoltare se mi fai
vincere chi legale i miei baffi ed è un
gran regalo e da parte di tony te lo
dico allora porca di quella ladra
[ __ ] in autostrada come faccio a
saltare qua sopra
non puoi perché se sei cosi sei troppo
indietro se sei cosi sei troppo avanti e
muori
[Musica]
beh sì
addio oddio oh mio dio oh mio dio ce
l'ho fatta bassa ragazzi bar mi sono
rotto le balle non voglio più continuare
nella mia vita giocare a sta roba non me
lo fate di fare vi prego vi supplico ok
ok basta basta no c'è il vostro cosa me
dai dai dai dai quante lungo mio dio
neanche quello di rock così lungo si ok
ok anche bravo bravo tiro su tiro su
più dei ming [ __ ] comunque ragazzi
se volete anche voi un nuovo coi baffi
lasciato un mi piace il velo procuro io
che è abbastanza inquietante ora che mi
metta fissavo come si deve cook ragazzi
conclude episodio spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto anche se per me non è stato
il massimo della vita è niente ragazzi
se il video vi è piaciuto come al solito
al sotto commento mi piace anche la pace
di facebook e come non gli video trovata
l'estizione se vorresti discreti i
civili devono passioni da ragazzi